[Music]
hello and welcome to a very special
episode of dear Hank and John or as I
like to call it Dear John and Sarah it's
a comedy podcast about death where my
wife Sarah and I answer your questions
give you do pious advice and bring you
all the week's news from both Mars and
AFC Wimbledon Hank is busy this week I
think he's working on the line edits for
his new novel an absolutely remarkable
thing which comes out in September and
is available for pre-order now and it's
so good and I'm not just saying that
because he is my brother it really is a
wonderful book it's also Sarah in the
top 20 on Amazon right now I'm so
thrilled for Hank it is incredible and
super exciting yeah so we're very happy
for Hank do Co preorder an absolutely
remarkable thing you can do it at your
local independent bookstore or also
elsewhere Sarah gave a short poem for us
today should we do one that somebody
recommended or should we do one that I
happen to have around let's do one that
you just happen to have okay okay this
week's poem comes from Mari Evans and it
goes like this
I who would encompass millions M adrift
on this my single bed that's so good
oh we should have you do all of the
short poems that was excellent Wow
well who among us has not felt bad it's
called college god from here is called
twenties all right let's get to some
questions from our listeners Sarah this
first question comes from ebony who
writes Dear John and Hank recently I was
shown the TED talk how to tie your shoes
initially skeptical I was certain that I
had nothing to fear
of course I know how to tie my shoes but
imagine my complete horror when I
discovered that I had in fact been tying
my shoelaces wrong for my whole life
I am now completely distraught I do not
know how to cope with this revelation
and I am now immensely fearful of other
such life-changing discoveries how do I
cope with the terrifying realization
that at any moment my life could
completely change any dubious advice
would be much appreciated no longer in
perfect harmony
so evany I think your first problem is
watching TED Talks cuz they give you
this false sense that you can master
your life and right there are right ways
and wrong ways to do things or or that
there are only right ways and wrong ways
to do things like that there is a one
right way to approach the world right
sometimes Ted's editorial voice does
veer a little too far into that
worldview well they make it seem like
there's like the secret Club of people
and and Ted presenters are the only ones
who belong to this club and they know
how to do life right like they're the
masters of the universe right but the
truth is
evany I watched this TED talk said and I
watched it together and I'm completely
unconvinced that this person's way of
tying shoes is better than the standard
way of tying shoes I am however
convinced that Sara's way of tying shoes
is better than either my way or the TED
talk guy way well I had my cousin Mark
teach me how to tie my shoes his way
when I was like an adult
yeah and it's a good way you actually go
to loops around before you pull it
through and it never comes loose except
for when you want it to right brilliant
it's not a double knot that it's a
double loop and the double loop means
that you can still like pull the tassels
or whatever and you get you get your
free shoelaces rather than getting that
like complicated knot yes my way of
tying shoes which I consider to be the
standard way is just the way that
everybody's familiar with the TED talk
guy way is to do a somewhat underhand
did not and then the knot is apparently
slightly stronger but here's the thing
ebony your real question is how do I
cope with the terrifying realization
that at any moment my life could
completely change and like that is a big
question and a good one and I think the
way that most of us cope with it is by
ignoring it as much as possible well
yeah and and this particular problem was
not really a problem for you before
right so
so yes it's hard to deal with change but
you know if it's working for you yes why
do we introduce problems into our lives
unnecessarily why can't we just say you
know what life isn't about maximizing
efficiency as you know Sarah I Drive 45
seconds when I Drive the kids to school
I take away that is 45 seconds longer
and Chris waters always makes fun of me
for this he says why do you turn onto
that Street if you turn to streets
earlier you would say 45 seconds and you
do this 200 times a year and it costs
you more than an hour and the answer is
I like that hour I like the hour that I
spend unnecessarily
taking the kids to school because it's
Pleasant for me the kids are usually in
a relatively good mood they usually are
we're talking about something or
listening to music and yes it is not the
most efficient or effective way to get
the kids to school but it is the way
that I like that's true although the
reason why you don't turn on the street
where you should turn is because you
don't have the map in your head so you
don't see your inefficiency no if you
had the map in your head it might bother
anymore it's true that I have absolutely
no map in my head when we moved when I
was a kid we moved houses when I was
about 14 years old and for the rest of
the time that I lived in Orlando Florida
before I drove anywhere I drove to my
old house because I had no idea how to
get anywhere except from my old house
it's like when I got my driver's license
and I got in the car for the first time
and my mom was with me and I turned to
her and I go how do we get to the store
she was kidding me you've been a
passenger for how long and ethical I
didn't have to pay attention right it
was completely unprepared but it's no
longer a problem thanks to smartphones
it's true neither Sarah Nora has a
particularly good sense of direction but
the long and short of it is ebony that
just keep tying your shoes or don't
whatever this next question comes from
Ben oh wait it's your turn
yeah ask a question it's my turn okay
the next question comes from Ireland
dear Hank and John I have been going to
a high school art class weekly for the
last few months but I feel like I
haven't gotten to know any of my other
classmates everyone in the class are
very shy or awkward and all of my
attempts to engage any of them in
conversation have failed I want to focus
on my art projects while I am there but
also make new friends any good
conversation starters I should try
should I try to make art jokes and hope
for the best
dubious advice would be appreciated I am
NOT a country Ireland well Sarah you
have been to a lot of art classes you
did art classes in high school I did how
do you make art class friends well you
don't you don't chat people up while
they're making art I will I will say
it's generally frowned upon to talk to
other people during art classes unless
you're doing a sort of collaborative
project mostly you kind of sit there and
you've got to think of your ideas and
work on it yourself and you know the
conversation happens kind of outside the
classroom or somewhere else so I
wouldn't try to make art jokes
although do you have any do you have any
art jokes John I don't have any off the
top of my head no I never took an art
class which will surprise you given my
mastery of visual expressions well then
you don't have to be masterful in visual
expression to take an art class common
misconception well you have to be
present and you have to try and you have
to be unafraid to fail oh it's the third
one I was ready for the first two it's
that I really just like failing so I
made I made friends in art classes
walking to class together walking after
class milling about after class or you
know if you really want to try and be
outgoing you can you know put out an ass
to see if anybody wants to go see an art
show together locally watch an art
related movie maybe watch an episode of
the art assignment available yeah
through PBS digital right now May
even do that um but I think you got it
you gotta try to be social outside of
class what about this is something I've
tried over the years in writing classes
and I found it to be very effective
what about complementing the work of
people you want to date that that I mean
complimenting other people works but you
have to like have a sincere and
interesting compliment that's good I
like that
mmm not that convincing but if you have
like a good critique that's mostly
complimentary it could work I remember
when we first started dating I've in
general I've been pretty good over the
years at finding specific compliments
for people's work whose work I admired
yeah I I actually think that's been one
of the secrets to my success is
complimenting people in a way that they
like that they're happy to have heard
that compliment I remember looking at
your artwork on your website and
thinking it was really good and
interesting and feeling visually drawn
to it and feeling like almost like I
kind of wanted to like leave inside of
those paintings or look at them from
different angles and stuff and having
absolutely no vocabulary for trying to
express to you what I thought was cool
about your work that's why you watched
the art assignment yeah yes Digital
Studios I I give you tips and pointers
for ways to talk about artwork um you
can look up the video how to critique
okay that's enough of a plug for my labs
that's good that's good that's
pre-ordering Hanks book yes but I think
I in in general though I think it is
really fun to connect to people through
their work and connect to people through
the stuff that they make we've all we've
done that the two of us but also with a
lot of our friends a lot of our closest
friends are people who the stuff that
they make whether it's the kids they
pair into or the art they make or other
work they do we find points of
connection there and that's always been
important for us and and talking about
art is
fantastic way to not talk about yourself
you know she's like another non you or
them subject right alright this next
question comes from Ben and I wanted to
ask it because it's something I have a
little bit of experience with Ben writes
a Dear John and hick I work at an
emergency room on the south side of
Chicago and because of this I've
witnessed some of the worst moments in
people's lives
I feel like cope with this fairly well
all things considered my problem is this
I feel like I'm lying to my friends and
family more and more every time I get a
simple question and like how was work
how was your day
I feel the need to protect them from
what I see and do no one wants to hear
about what I actually had to do in the
course of a day and in fact it might
gross them out so I answer with fine or
okay or something else equally vague how
do I remain
genuine and authentic to my friends and
family without grossing them out and
exposing them to the worst sides of
humanity Benjamin Benjamin it's a good
name specific sign off to a very serious
question I need to lighten it up there
at the end yeah maybe that's the key
maybe just every time somebody says how
you doing you just say Benjamin
well John you actually have some direct
experience here but maybe I'll go first
with my more dubious advice ah which is
that I think that it's it's risky to to
lie to them or to gloss over it if you
really want to have genuine and deep
relationships with the people in your
life and you kind of do have to rain on
the parade and tell them about what's
going on they probably will be
interested although it's hard to hear
and it does drag down a conversation you
know maybe hide pepper in some of the
possibly funnier or just gross and not
horribly depressing things that happen
or you could create like a rating system
for your day for the people in your life
like somebody you see every day you
could be like okay 10 is super bad one
was great everybody came into the ER
healthy today and then
you could say well it was a nine it was
it was bad but let's move on kind of
thing so you can be honest but not
really depressing I think it's all
contextual i I think there are times
when somebody you know when you're
buying an ice cream cone and somebody
says how was your day that's not a
moment for you to be like well listen it
was brutal right and there are times
even in conversations with people we're
close to and people we love when we want
to kind of gloss over things and I think
that's okay I don't think that's lying
even if you said that was a little rough
but I'm really happy to be here like
that isn't lying it's just I don't
really feel the need to get into it
right now and when I worked at the
Children's Hospital that's what I did a
lot and it was only occasionally when
someone would say to me has it been
difficult or halves or you I know you
just got back from an on call one of the
closest people in my life might say I
know you just got back from being on
call for 24 or 40 hours or whatever it
was did it did anything difficult to
happen is there anything you want to
talk about and then it becomes a moment
where you can have those conversations
Benjamin and talking about this there's
one thing I want to say which is that
unlike me you are not presumably a 21
year old deeply narcissistic kid with a
lot of emotional baggage Europe you're
great but I often use the incredible
difficulties that I was going through at
that time in my life and the real trauma
that I was close to and that I witnessed
as a way of taking over conversations or
acting like my problems were more
important than other people's problems
and that time is feeling like my
problems were more important than other
people's problems
and that's just not true and so I think
that's also important to remember you
have to make space for other people's
problems and if you feel if you're
minimizing other people's problems
because they don't feel serious to you I
think that you're forgetting
one of the core things about being a
person which is that we don't live our
lives only in the context of we're
suffering we also live our lives in the
context of the previous things that have
happened to us working at a hospital
hard and I really admire you and I that
was it was the hardest six months of my
life yes we appreciate what you do
Benjamin yeah thank you okay this next
question comes from someone we don't
quite know how to pronounce their name
ass ass I think it's ants dear you can
John what's the right thing to say when
someone's complimenting your furniture
like oh I really like that sofa should
the answer be Thanks I always feel weird
saying that as I didn't make the so far
anything but I did choose it from many
other nice sofas this has recently been
on my mind a lot as I moved into a new
apartment with my boyfriend a few weeks
ago with greetings from Latvia oh yeah
now that I realized that answers from
Latvia it's probably not an s' is there
a more American value sound yeah anyway
I think that this brings me to the that
response when you say oh I'm sorry if
someone says they're second they say oh
it's not your fault you know that's not
what they're saying they're just saying
that they're sorry that you are sick and
it must be a terrible scenario so you're
aware that it's not their theory and
just like this when they're saying I
really like that sofa they don't think
you made it that is correct
unless you happen to be an upholsterer
we have not accounted for this
possibility the Latvian upholsterer
possibility you might have mentioned
that however I feel like that would have
been in the question so I think yes you
say Thanks but as I was reading this I
came up with a thought which is that if
you don't like that question you need
some sort of a large and
obvious curiosity in your new apartment
they're going to suck in all the
interest right and prevent anyone from
picking sofa comments no one will ever
say a word about your sofa when they
look and see you're life-size cutout of
Olympic swimmer Mark Spitz that's the
best possible one in Latvia too because
I assume that the vast majority of
people will be like and hairy man in a
speedo but you know I don't know what
your Mark Spitz cutout is but I think
you and your boyfriend need to find
something because maybe they're
complimenting your sofa because your
apartments a little bare and they don't
know what else to compliment yes make
some art together you'll be yeah maybe I
know if you prove it here's another
great distraction get a big roll of
paper you and your boyfriend get naked
paint yourselves in a non-toxic paint
press yourself to the paper let it dry
hang it on the wall
no one will compliment your sofa again
do we have a thing in our house that is
the thing that people compliment and
makes them not notice everything else
the answer is that we do but I genuinely
don't know if you're going to guess it
how about our antique TV that doesn't
work the antique TV that doesn't work
got a lot of play in our old house yes
what gets a lot of play in our new house
Sarah
we got a dank secret room always forget
about the dang secret the secret room is
it you have to tell people about it cuz
it's secret right but when you tell
people about the secret room and you let
them like you know move the book that
results in the secret room opening up
everyone everyone gets the childlike
wonder in their eyes
true it
brings a lot of joy but I think we can
no longer call it secret John because
it's just that room that opens via
bookcase with a book that you pull
because you tell everyone who comes to
our house Fed Ex man yes what it comes
from this is a secret room and they're
always like yeah I do the other thing
that gets a lot of attention in our
house and rightfully so is our
incredible duh toilet ok look absolutely
no further explanation we're going to
move on to another question this one
from Ryan a real Ryan Sarah Wow you
probably don't know why that's such a
big deal this must be a dear Hank and
John joke I must clarify before we get
any further that I have listened to this
podcast before you have but I I don't
know the Ryan joke are jokes funnier
when you have to explain them but this
joke certainly won't be because I also
don't even really remember the Ryan joke
but anyway Ryan's are a thing so a real
Ryan we have a lot of people who claim
to be Ryan to write in but this is a
proper Ryan although who knows for sure
they didn't send in a driver's license
which is what we usually look for when
trying to confirm Ryan this Ryan writes
Dear John and Hank I'm a 24-year old
Ryan now that is the exact kind of thing
Orion would say and our experience
Ryan's frequently identified myself ok
so ok I'm a 24 year old Ryan I'm also
terribly dyslexic I'm not illiterate but
close I try to avoid reading but
pursuing a master's in chemistry makes
that difficult I've gotten this farm
with the use of text-to-speech software
that is built into my MacBook I'm trying
to read more consuming more stories
comics graphic novels audio books etc I
have a problem though there is a weird
sad hollow feeling that ruins me when a
story I enjoy ends is this normal how do
you process it how do people love to
read if it hurts like this people lived
and breathed inside my head
and now their story is over I will hear
no more from them in time will I just
become callous to this feeling sad and
hollow Ryan I love this question yes
just this captures the beauty of reading
entirely and that sadness is just you
know what makes it a bittersweet
experience but I think Brian's on to
something with the graphic novels or or
maybe like something that's released in
serial format something that comes out
again and again so you don't have to
give up on your character that's
something that lasts forever debate the
baby-sitters club is the example from my
childhood I loved reading the
baby-sitters Club books because they
would give me a little bit of that I
often hear people describe it as a book
hangover a little bit of that sad empty
feeling that you get at the end of a
book but it wouldn't last for long
because there was always baby-sitters
club number 32 just published and so
there was there was excitement around
that that said I have come to really
love that feeling that a great book
leaves me with it's a weird feeling and
I it is melancholic but it isn't for me
totally unpleasant I really love being
so transported and caring so much about
a fictional world that when I am on the
other side of that reading experience I
yearn for it and I miss it and I miss
those people and I feel like I care
about those people I can't get that
feeling anywhere else and it's not a
purely enjoyable feeling but it is a
really kind of deep feeling for me yeah
so I think the answer is that you won't
become callous to the feeling maybe
you'll learn to enjoy the feeling or be
able to sort of enjoy marinating in the
the leftovers of the reading experience
I just finished his 80 Smith's swing
time yeah and I found it disturbing in a
lot of ways very good but I don't yet
want to dive back into another novel
just yet so usually after
a novel or like a story that I'm really
into maybe he'll read some articles some
neat some shorter things some New Yorker
that's stacked up because you can't ever
read them all or you know maybe um I'll
look at a magazine or maybe some
nonfiction so I think there's just ways
that you deal with it the most recent
book hangover I had not to go back to a
subject that's going to be a frequent
topic over the next eight months was
after reading Hank's book an absolutely
remarkable thing I really did though and
I hadn't had the feeling that intensely
in a long time where I loved those
characters and I wanted to spend more
time with them and I loved how they
loved each other I loved the way they
cared about each other and I did both
things that I have in my real life and
also things that I had at other points
in my real life that I miss having you
know that feeling of being Beverly when
we were in our 20s and in Chicago and we
had these wonderful wonderful friend
groups and we remember the best summer
ever when Sam and Shannon announced that
it was going to be the best summer ever
and we were always grilling out and the
weather was always perfect and we were
well we just loved living on getting
Street in The Bookseller had opened up
and so we had a local bookstore we could
walk to and a great bar and we felt
comfortable enough in our own skins
finally at the end of our 20s to have
this magical summer together that's the
way an absolutely remarkable thing made
me feel I cannot wait to read it I'm so
excited to read it and I cannot wait to
have my Hank green book hangover very
soon yeah absolutely
which reminds me that today's podcast is
brought to you by Hank Green's new book
an absolutely remarkable thing available
in September in bookstores everywhere
it's also brought to you by Mark Spitz
former Olympic sport how did you get to
Mark Spitz
take me there do you have a life-size
cutout of Mark Spitz even hiding from me
this whole time
no I I was I don't know how I got there
but I once looked for mark spitz posters
on eBay and are you into Mark Spitz I
really don't know how I got there I you
know I like to look first weird stuff on
eBay
ya know that's why eBay exists there's
no Val good lyric trying to fight the
sense of dread with temporal things yeah
that's my description of what eBay feels
like okay which reminds me the today's
podcast is also brought to you by eBay
eBay trying to fight this sense of dread
with temporal things and lastly this
podcast is brought to you by Ben's day
at work don't ask about it no don't ask
about Ben's day it wasn't great today's
podcast also has an actual sponsor and
we're so grateful to them today's actual
sponsor is hellofresh which is a meal
kit delivery service that shops plans
and delivers your favorite step-by-step
recipes and pre measured ingredients so
you can just cook eat and enjoy you can
get $30 off your first week of
hellofresh by going to hell afresh calm
and entering either dear Hank or Dear
John there's no dear Sarah sorry about
that but it's dear Hank or Dear John I
recommend Dear John but they both work
we made a healthy fresh meal last night
last night John and I made from
hellofresh these gorgeous greens farro
bowls with grilled zucchini and
asparagus and they were fantastic was
really good really great it was
vegetarian but really filling and very
well-balanced and the perfect amount it
was excellent it was my favorite meal
delivery service I've ever had and I
just thought the flavors were really
good and I also thought the portions
were really good this is an important
thing for those of us who are trying to
watch our figures portion control is the
biggest struggle for me and I just felt
great after eating that meal you know
how if you just if you can just bring
yourself to not eat too much and eat the
right amount you feel really great after
you don't eat second dinner I didn't
need second dinner after eating the
gorgeous greens farival also it was very
easy to prepare which is a big plus for
us because we are always trying to make
dinner while also trying to deal with
what we call kid dinner there's very
specific
kind of cooking that involves cheese and
carbohydrates yeah and the other great
thing about hellofresh is that if you're
feeling really uninspired on your
various social media accounts you can
brag about the amazing meal that you
just made and in this case tag it with
hello fresh picks that's right we really
loved our heavily fresh meal we're
looking forward to getting more of them
and we really genuinely recommend the
service it's hellofresh com
you can get $30 off your first week of
Helen fresh by entering dear Hank or
Dear John again I recommend Dear John
okay but back to our questions this next
one comes from Kelly I've never been
into politics much until the past year
and a half I know if I want things to
change I need to get involved and the
quote easiest first step would be
calling my Senators and Representatives
to voice my concerns why is this so
daunting I'm 30 years old for goodness
sake I know they are just humans like I
am but for some reason I get such
anxiety thinking about calling I could
send an email but I've heard that
politicians pay more attention to phone
calls political advice for introverts
Kelly this is something I also struggle
with yeah we both John and I really
dislike actually calling people and yes
I if I could give anyone some advice for
looking for their life partner one of
you should feel comfortable calling
strangers by two things I think it's
good to have at least one spender and at
least one saver oh we're both spenders
and neither of us like to call people I
disagree I don't think we're both
spenders oh really
you think you're not as bender no I when
I look at the secret room bookcase every
time I look at it I think to myself this
was the action of a saver this is the
kind of thing only a saver would have
purchased but who had the wherewithal
and the contacts to get this bookcase
made and paid for oh definitely you it's
definitely you I think you actually made
the relevant phone calls I did neither
of us is particularly good at calling I
would say if you want to have a job if
you want to have job security for the
rest of your life
be the kind of person who's good at
calling strangers right it's such a
great life skill but we don't have it
and neither does Kelly so here's my
advice Kelly you just got to work
yourself up and then what I like to do
with difficult things is break them into
tiny little constituent parts so I go to
five calls org I look at the script I
read through everything I see who I'm
gonna call
I look at the number I think about
dialing the number I dialed the number I
wait for a while before hitting call
just to psych myself up remind myself of
the stuff I want to say then I hit call
eight times out of ten I end up with a
voicemail message which is perfect so
that's one of the nice things especially
if you call during a busy time you're
probably just gonna get a voicemail
which so easy to do and then I just do
my best to say it I always stumble over
my words and then and then I just hang
up as quickly as possible and then I
reward myself I get I tell myself okay
you have five minutes to do whatever you
want you can eat candy you can go on
reddit you can do anything that will
bring you pleasure and then we're gonna
make one more call and then you're done
for the week
wait but can we back up a little bit
here because I feel like it's okay to
not call your representatives I listen
the most other things you can do this to
be an active member in this democracy
you can vote that's the most important
thing I really feel like if you're if
you're paying attention to the news and
the issues and the people who are
running for positions in your area then
you're doing a hell of a lot of work
already yeah you're doing a good job
I agree the most important thing you can
do is vote the second most important
thing you can probably do is register
other people to vote care we go help
organize to get other people to vote do
you remember when we went door-to-door
to encourage people to register to vote
John I do this is relevant I do I feel
that this is relevant it's nothing that
neither of us really wanted to do that
we felt that we should write and we did
and we
went door-to-door and a neighborhood and
we used to go to the door yeah we'd
knock during the bell and then we kind
of agree in those few moments okay are
you going first for this one or am i and
I remember the first time it was gonna
be John's turn John was like okay it's
good it's good it's gonna be me this
time woman opens the door pause pause
John I kinda was like okay now's your
chance and then I I swept in there oh
sorry I would have stood silent in front
of that person for seven years
if you hadn't begun to talk yeah I was
already they tell you what to say they
you say your name and then you state
your purpose
yeah and I felt very comfortable just
not telling somebody how they should
vote but just giving them the
opportunity to register just a quick
update on you might hear some noise
outside it's a buddy of ours who works
at the local restaurant he's very
excited about seeing one of his friends
so that's a personal update in case you
can hear that they also appeared to
maybe be setting off some firecrackers
they're so excited to be seeing each
other anymore
but back to political activism right and
there's there's other things you can do
besides going to register people to vote
or calling your representative you can
do something like make a really cool
poster but advertises your particular
issues of concern yeah there are other
things to do besides calling I
completely agree you don't have to call
but it is one way of trying to move the
needle a little bit especially in
between elections I think a lot of us
feel kind of powerless in between
elections but the most important thing
that we can do is vote in 2018 and make
sure that we're registered to vote in
2018 so if you're not registered to vote
or II if you're not sure that you're
registered to vote get registered right
now I don't mean like getting a car
accident by pulling out your phone but
like I mean pull over right now get
yourself into a safe space and register
to vote it is so important if we had 100
percent or even 80 percent voter turnout
I think that we would like American
governance a lot more and so I really
encourage you to make your voice heard
and to register to vote and to vote in
November all right this next question
comes from Lenny who asks Dear John and
Hank what should I do with a guy who
thinks reading novels is useless and
lame and won't get me anywhere furiously
whenI dumb pimping fast
yeah farewell sweet prince
next question yep I'm not I mean that's
it that's really all that's really all
you can say look especially if when he
clearly likes to read yeah so if he
can't if he if he can't appreciate your
desire to read fiction then it's just
not gonna work here's my issue with the
question it's when when he asks what
should I do with the guy who thinks
reading novels is useless and lame look
that's fine I think it's wrong but it's
fine but the end won't get me anywhere
no no no I don't even think that that
part is fine I think that it's fine to
not read fiction yourself yes but I
don't think it's okay to impose that on
other people exactly that's that's yes
it's fine right live your life but don't
tell other people how to live their
reading lives for the love of God you
know who read fiction James Joyce you
know who read fiction Toni Morrison come
on I also think like name all of the
things in the world that might be
useless and lame there are so many more
things that can be construed as useless
reading you know where or what what do
we do that isn't useless because we're
all gonna end up in the same place right
yeah like you know what won't get you
anywhere spending your whole life
telling other people that they're
reading choices are useless and lame
that's not gonna get you anywhere in the
long run Winnie I think it's time to
walk the earth away okay our next
question
from Phoebe dear Hank and John I am
friends with a guy I am a girl who I
went to a dance with last weekend we
attended as friends but in the midst of
school dance insanity we ended up slow
dancing I like him and I think he likes
me so my question is how do two people
proceed after accidentally slow dancing
with each other not friends with
Chandler and Rachel Phoebe ah Phoebe
this is awesome this is the opposite of
Winnie's question where's Monica
oh she must be friends with Monica maybe
she is friends with Monica alternate way
maybe judging by what I'm guessing is
Phoebe's age she's not that familiar a
friend or also Joey's missing okay
if we're gonna say that Joey's missing
Sarah then we might as well get into the
endless cast of four straight friends
carry a prominent core member of the
friend group
Sarah everyone knows that that
television show friends is about a group
of five very close friends and the sixth
person who is Joey who is a like not
central character in any of their lives
no he's a huge character strongly
disagree okay anyway let's get back to
the question here which is which is
wonderful what a wonderful question um
how do you proceed you just you just
keep proceeding you've friends and maybe
more and you know what this is a
beautiful time in a relationship where
you like each other but it's undefined
it's a beautiful time in retrospect like
when you're inside of it it's kind of an
anxious time alright that's check but it
is a beautiful time looking back on it
for sure yeah here's my favorite part of
the question Sarah is in the midst of
school dance insanity we ended up slow
dancing here here's my take Phoebe I
don't think that you ended up slow
dancing because you know the school
dance
insanity overtook both of you and you
just were feeling the vibe of it all and
you were you just suddenly found
yourself slow dancing I strongly think
that if you really examine your motives
you're gonna find that you ended up slow
dancing because you
both wanted to be slow-dancing and that
means that you know that's a step on a
path maybe or maybe not it's up to you
but I think you just keep walking that
path and maybe say maybe you know what
you could say you gotta throw this out
there you could say Ross
I assume that's his name I really
enjoyed slow dancing with you at first I
thought it was only because of the
school dance insanity that we ended up
slow dancing together but the more I
think about the more I think like I
liked I liked slow dancing with you I
thought it was fun what do you think of
that is that too far me it might be too
tired I don't know I don't know it she
doesn't seem like she's dying to know
what he thinks so I I think I think
she's in a good place because she's just
kind of toeing the line and I believe in
protecting one's own interests here like
if it works out great and if it doesn't
NBD that is a true-blue Sarah green
answer that reveals something deep about
your character I think and it is very
true like at what point in our romantic
relationship do you think that you
thought to yourself if we break up this
is now gonna be a big deal it was pretty
soon after we got together I was gonna
ask you if it was before or after we got
engaged definitely before come on yeah
because I would say the moment I
realized that are breaking up would be a
huge deal to me was like maybe three
months before we started dating before
yeah Wow yeah I was like I don't know if
I want to start this whole process
because it would be devastating because
I liked you so much cuz like we got
along so well as friends and we had
these wonderful email conversations
right and then I and I remember you came
to a party in my house and at the end of
that party I was like oh we're gonna
have to make a decision about this yeah
we are you both of us
right cuz we clearly liked each other
yeah yeah
he's some right but I don't know that we
really understood what what it was right
we were in a similar situation really to
the situation Phoebe's engine that's
sure and I I did I did enjoy I enjoyed
that process I liked we had great but it
many repartee before we started dating
we did but the other thing to note since
they're pretty young is that it's all um
it's about whether you guys get along
and whether you have good chemistry but
it's also of course about timing so mate
you know maybe it is your your time with
this guy and and maybe you need to date
a few other people first before before
this guy for real so who knows that said
we have lots of friends who started
dating in eighth grade and are still
together do a telex we have one well two
because there are a couple okay one that
seems like an exception to the rule no
it is possible it is possible I was I
was gonna I was gonna try to imagine
what life would have been like if I'd
married my eighth grade girlfriend yeah
but then of course I realized that I did
not have one it was a tough year yeah it
was a tough year yeah anyway Phoebe I
I think congratulations that you have a
special relationship with another person
whom you like and that may lead to
something romantic and may not oh that's
great advice Sara that's lovely
okay sir it's time to get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon would you like to go first I
assume that you have some extremely
carefully prepared Mars news yeah I'm a
little worried about this delivery here
since I don't have a very deep knowledge
of Mars but I will tell you what I've
learned through my extensive research
okay and that's that um NASA's next
mission to Mars passed a key test in the
past week in extending the solar arrays
that will power the insight spacecraft
once it lands on the Red Planet this
November I wasn't just really bad from
my phone I swear it didn't sound like
you or no no um so anyway it seems like
they've been doing a lot of
but now they're there really it's
getting closer to the time and they're
sort of going through the motions of the
things that won't happen again till this
thing actually gets to Mars Wow so my
understanding of this is that we are in
a period where NASA is a attempting to
essentially land a much nicer Mini
Cooper on Mars than the Mini Cooper that
we landed named curiosity a few years
ago and that is very exciting but
critically it will not have any humans
on it
right which leaves open the possibility
that this podcast will change its name
in 2028 franken's well I will I will say
looking at the fan like solar panels
yeah are part of this they're very
beautiful does it look like a peacock
it's very well designed I will say I can
take a look I think it's kind of
gorgeous it is beautiful that is really
pretty like a flower yeah
well the news from AFC Wimbledon is also
beautiful and wonderful and amazing as
Sarah knows because she was there as I
was celebrating AFC Wimbledon beat
Blackpool to to nil on January 20th this
was a huge win on the heels of their nil
nil draw against the franchise currently
flying its trade in Milton Keynes AFC
Wimbledon won to nil with goals from
Liam Trotter and Joe picket Sarah have
you heard that name before
you haven't no you know why I know he's
new he's brand new we just signed him it
was his first game and with his second
touch of the ball as an AFC Wimbledon
player he scored he's new and I don't
want to get ahead of myself but he's
amazing he's 24 years old pressure we
signed him from Maidstone United a team
in the fifth tier of English football I
don't want to put too much pressure on
him this early in his AFC Wimbledon he's
24 okay I don't want to put too much
pressure on him this early in his AFC
Wimbledon career but I have started
calling him the Maidstone E and Messi
because I think he is going to be the
greatest football player in England's
history very exciting we scored two
goals which isn't does not happen very
often and we didn't give up any which is
even better
and that means that for the first time
in a long long time for the first time
in many many weeks AFC Wimbledon are no
longer in the bottom four places in
Ligue 1 we are out of the relegation
zone we are all the way up in 19th I
mean can you even breathe the air up
here it's so deoxygenated we have 31
points after 27 games a negative 7 goal
differential that our goal differential
than any of the teams around us sitting
comfortably joyfully in 19th and Sarah
what if I told you that the news gets
even better still I wouldn't believe you
but but it's true because while we are
in 19th guess who we have pushed down
into 21st place a relegation spot the
worst team of all time literally the
worst team of all time the franchise
currently applying its trade Milton
Keynes now of course if they get
relegated they can just steal a league
spot from a team in the third tier like
they did back in 2002 so it won't be a
problem for them of course but but it is
I have to say a little pleasant to see a
team that still insists on calling
themselves the Dons despite having
absolutely no association with Wimbledon
at all in any way in the relegation
spots if huh if somehow AFC Wimbledon
ended up staying up that other team ends
up going down that would mean not having
to play them next season which would
also be lovely
so yeah let's keep our let's keep our
hopes alive may I ask a question you may
so how far not to get too ambitious here
but how far out of the relegation zone
does one have to be before one doesn't
worry about entering the relegation zone
great question
52 points if you get to 52 points we're
not going to get relegated and until
probably and until we get to 52 points
I'm going to worry and how many points
do we have 31 okay and we have work to
do we have 19 games left so we need from
those 19 games
need about 21 points okay it should be
doable with Joe Piggot forget about that
Sarah let me answer your question with a
question
hmm is it possible that AFC Wimbledon
will be promoted to the second tier of
English football is it possible that on
the back of Joe Piggott we will rise
from 21st all the way up to sixth place
shouldn't we suspend that that hope a
little later in the season winning the
play-off semi-final and then going to
Wembley again flying out to Wembley with
my son and my father and my spouse
mm-hmm
maybe maybe and enjoying the greatest
comeback in the history of football it's
possible Sarah it's possible through Joe
Piggott so many things are possible
do you have any sort of song for Joe
picket yeah I've been thinking about
trying to develop one I I tried to buy
him in my FIFA game but he isn't in the
game because he plays in a tier that's
too low yeah I've been thinking about a
good Joe Pickett song if you have any
suggestions actually let us know on
Twitter or on the patreon to
patreon.com/scishow
Hank and John I know that the AFC
Wimbledon fans are going to need a great
joke Pickett song to go along with their
classic Lyle Taylor baby
[Music]
Sara thank you for parting with me thank
you for asking me to part with you John
it's been a pleasure and I really
appreciate you doing thanks gonna hello
fresh both for providing us with a
wonderful dinner last night in the form
of the gorgeous greens bearable and for
sponsoring today's episode of dear Hank
and John and thanks to all of you for
listening again you can find out more
about our podcast at the patreon
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John you
can find out more about Sarah at the art
assignment you can just google if they
have a website it's the hard assignment
com
oh that was a good one you picked a good
URL which John Green Comm was available
but that realtor in Southern Mississippi
is sure had it for a long time our
podcast is produced by rosianna halse
rojas and sheridan Gibson it's edited by
the brilliant Nick Jenkins or head of
community and communications is Victoria
Panzano the theme music you're listening
to right now was made by gunnarolla
thank you again for listening and as
they say in our hometown don't forget to
be awesome
[Music]